[Musique]
info ou intox et avec anthony st léger
bonjour anthony on s'intéresse ce soir
certaines images qui ont circulé après
l'éruption il ya deux jours du volcan je
prends mon souffle hung à tonga unga
appareils sur les îles ravry tongs à huy
et des images souvent impressionnante et
des dégâts qui le sont tout autant
contenu évidemment de la puissance de l
explosion on va s'intéresser à deux
exemples ce soir donc le premier alors
les images que vous voyez ici c'est un
sujet réalisé par france 24 ce sont des
vraies images le premier raison c'est
celui ci regardez on voit un homme qui
boxe ardemment à un arbre cette vidéo
allait elle a été partagée par ce tweet
au qui se présente comme un journaliste
indien et elle a reçu plus d'un million
et demi de vue et on la trouve également
sur facebook alors cette vidéo si
surprenante soit parce que vous allez
voir que le boxeur en question notamment
va être happé par la vague vient-elle
des îles tonga et bien non la réponse
elle nous vient d'une simple recherche
d'image inversée via cet outil que l'on
connaît bien a désormais elle nous
renvoie sur youtube la vidéo originale à
la voici alors elle n'a pas été
trafiqués la vague a bien eu lieu on né
le 6 décembre dernier mais on n'est pas
aux îles tonga on est en indonésie dans
la province de rio et dans la légende de
cette vidéo on lit le mot bono alors ça
n'a rien à voir avec youtube you to
pardon bono c'est le mot indonésien pour
mascaret c'est à dire cette surélévation
soudaine de l'eau que l'on voit à
l'écran justement que ce soit d'une
rivière ou d'un fleuve et qui provoque
donc des vagues importantes le deuxième
exemple lui aussi a été utilisée acteurs
pour montrer les conséquences du tsunami
consécutive à l'explosion du volcan oui
le deuxième exemple voici c'est de cette
compilation justement de vidéo on
retrouve notre troisième exemple en bas
et puis il ya ces deux autres personnes
la dame en eau et puis l'homme au milieu
là encore c'est une recherche d'image
inversée qui nous permettent de trouver
l'origine de ces deux vidéos le 6
décembre en l'occurrence pour celles ci
on est toujours sur youtube et le 7
décembre pour cet autre l'homme en rouge
et ces deux personnes que vous vous
voulez retrouver en fait dans la toute
première vidéo c'est le même endroit le
même événement filmé par trois personnes
est différente et qu'on est qu'ils ont
été utilisés sur les réseaux sociaux
pour commenter l'actualité des tonga ce
qui est intéressant dans l'exemple de ce
soir c'est que ce le fait d'utiliser des
images impressionnantes pour un autre
phénomène phénomène c'est assez
récurrent lorsqu'il s'agit de
catastrophe naturelle est d'utiliser
notamment des hashtag comme par exemple
celui ci ou encore ceux là qui ont été
utilisées donc dans les deux tweets en
question pourquoi pour susciter de
l'engagement pour obtenir aussi plus
d'abonnés en jouant sur le flou d'image
mais pas seulement aussi sur la
confusion bien évidemment est très
souvent dans ces cas là et bien c'est
l'émotion c'est l'empathie qui prennent
le pas sur la réflexion surtout merci
anthony info ou intox avec anthony saint
léger